greetings from podcastville [__]
it's uncle joey's joint it's wednesday
well
it's thursday the eighth of
[__] october
rest in peace mr running let me explain
something to you
uncle joey's joint is brought to you by
manscaped
listen to scientists over at manscape
that released their first
nose hair trimmer i do not have mine
because it's still boxed up somewhere
but when i unwhack it
i will take it out it's called the weed
whacker everybody's doing video calls
right now and i got to tell you
the only thing that the camera's picking
up are the spider legs that are sticking
out of your nose
even my [__] nose is all [__] up
since i can't find
my weed whacker enough snuff out nose
hair with the best
that's manscaped listen you know about
manscape i've already told you all about
it
how they keep your balls safe when
you're trimming your muffler
now you could do the same job for your
nose
right now just just for the [__]
just for today right now you get 20
off and free shipping when you're
pressing the special code nose pubes
at manscape.com you'll never get a deal
like this on nose candy anywhere
in fact cocaine prices are up i found
out from a friend of mine
it's back up to 1800 it's [__] up
anyway i'm giving you 20
off and free shipping at manscape.com
with code those pubes what the [__] are
you waiting for
go whack those [__] weeds out of your
snotty [__] nose
the church is also brought to you by
express vpn
listen dog you take a [__] in front of
people
just drop the trout and take a hot dump
where everyone can see you
of course not you go into a store you're
not a [__] animal
you want privacy in those moments right
that's why
i use and recommend expressvpn
it encrypts your data when you're online
so no one can see
what you're up to if you want to whack
off the midgets jumping on each other in
bulgaria
boom nobody knows knife fights dog
fights idris elba it's the real [__]
expressvpn works
with any streaming service hulu bbc
netflix and youtube you name it it's
fast no buffering
and stream in hd and it works on all
devices
so do me a favor go to expressvpn.com
slash church and get your extra three
months of expressvpn
for free what are you talking about joey
it's free you [__]
show the support the show watch what the
[__] you want
and protect yourself at expressvpn.com
church the church is also brought to you
by you ready for this one
this is the best blue chew guys remember
the days when you always standing at
attention
ready to give your lady a [__]
stabbing there's nothing worse than lip
than lip dink all right nothing worse
than dead dick
if you've got a weak dick uncle joey's
got the face
blue chew right there it's the first
chewable dick pill
same fda improved active ingredient
that's in cyalis
and viagra this isn't the horny goat
weed you get from abdul in the [__]
corner store
this is science so right now they got a
special offer for the
for the joint family visit bluetooth.com
that's bluechew.com and get your first
shipment free
when you press in code church just pay
file and shipping
and again that's blue b-l-u-e
like the color of the dick veins that's
going to be popping out when you hit
that blue chew
dog and thank you for continuing to
sponsor
our show so the show is brought to you
by manscape
bluechu and expressvpn
let's light the [__] candle
and get this party started
what's happening you bad [__]
uncle joey here thursday
october the 8th it's a beautiful [__]
day
to be alive thank you very much for
watching the first show
and supporting us it's a great week so
far
i'm very sorry for any van halen fans
that was uh
it was [__] up for me i'll tell you
because uh
i don't know i just felt like the same
day i felt
i felt the same way i felt the day randy
rhodes died
i still remember getting picked up in
to go out and there was no internet then
and my friends were like randy rhodes
died it's so weird how
you don't know somebody like i don't
know randy rhodes i didn't know already
man and i never met
eddie van halen i saw him one time where
i used to buy weed in studio city i saw
him but i don't say nothing to people
i'm in my [__] business
and that's the only time i saw him i saw
him in 78 or 79 opening up for black
sabbath
and then i saw him one other time in the
[__] 80s and they were
true [__] mendes and if you don't
believe me
that video i played this morning will
let you know how strong of a [__]
band van halen was in 1981
39 [__] years ago they were as strong
as
[__] death on stage and say whatever
you want about david lee roth i never
said he was the best singer ever
but when he was up there doing when he
was on
that [__] was on but we're not
talking about david leroy
we're talking about eddie van halen and
i'm very sorry
there's a ton of van halen fans i know
that would ask since day one
you know as soon as i heard the news i
called my buddy guy tabasco
because there's no bigger van halen fan
than that guy poor bastard
so i called him up uh my other buddy
timmy
you know and they were hurting you know
people hurt man especially now
uh things hurt a little bit more during
this covenant because you have more time
to think about it
like i went as soon as i i found out he
died i
had to play dead anyway with jimmy
florentine's kids and a bunch of his
friends and my daughter
and even jimmy was like in shock i know
he did something for serious radio last
night
for ozzie's boneyard they did like some
type of memorial from him or whatever
that you know eddie van halen was just
[__] uh
revolutionary if you don't know about
him i mean i know you guys love guns and
roses and joe perry and aerosmith
i love a bunch of guitar players but i
got to tell you something
you know when it comes to [__] van
halen i'm gonna tell you a little secret
when i was a kid and i started going out
to concerts and [__] like that
they would tell you don't even worry
about the opening band
don't even worry about the opening band
we were from north bergen new jersey
so we had till 8 30 to get to the garden
that means we can leave a [__]
quarter to eight
you know get the bus into the city walk
from the
port authority to the garden in [__]
10 minutes
for van when van halen went on tour with
sabbath i'm gonna
i'm not gonna lie to you and tell you
the only album from sabbath i had at the
time was [__] paranoid i didn't know
anything about black sabbath
i just went on a [__] win some guys
from my neighbor were going
and they said do you want to come and i
was like what the [__] i'm not doing
nothing here
and they said wait do you see the
opening [__] that and i'll tell you
guys
when i got there i don't know how
[__] old that was i was young
but they blew me the [__] away and i was
into led zeppelin
and into all that [__] listen it was
hard to walk out of there and not
recognize the talent
that was eddie [__] van halen so for
you van halen guys do what i did last
night i just listened
to everything last night my wife went
out
uh so when i got back at like eight
o'clock i took a shower i washed my
[__] i ate some dinner
i smoked the [__] number and then uh
i just started from one i started from
van halen eruption and it was [__]
tremendous
and then i went out to van halen two
women and children first
1984 is a spectacular album the one
diver down is manzamort i don't know
what the other one is but then
[__] fair warning is a [__]
monster
and i posted two songs this morning from
fair warning just because
that this month it's just a monster
[__] out you know listen man
when we were kids guy tabasco lived next
door to me and his brother mike were big
uh
van gaal fans and we would torture him
like just torture him especially
i got mad at van halen after they put
the the david lee post up
in the middle of him with chains on and
the [__] women and children first
that's when van halen lost me
as a band but i was always another van
halen fan
as a band they lost him because of david
leroy's getting tied up i didn't like
that too much at the time
i'm a catholic you know what i'm saying
it's not like i'm a boy scout
right now they're trying to [__] get
people to see the boy scouts you're in
no danger these people don't [__]
remember
these people don't [__] remember
every night i'm watching tv they're
running an ad
have the boy scouts molested you let me
let me think well i'll tell you my story
with the [__] boy scouts
i was i wanted to be a boy scout like
the kid across the street's a boy scout
i felt like tortured him the other day
but i couldn't say nothing to him he's a
boy scout you know he's a weeble i was a
wee blow for one [__] day
and i could tell you one thing he was in
the back of a church in union city
it was across the street from the
four-star dying i don't know what the
name of that church is
but there's a theater next to that
church that george collins and hbo
special
in but that church behind there they
used to have like
sundays or saturdays you could become a
boy scout and you know me i'm a [__]
nerd
i fell in love with the patches when i
was a kid i love patches so
they give you a patch for everything for
lighting the match for cleaning your ass
for rubbing two sticks together the
whole thing by the end of the week you
got 19 [__] patches
i went to one [__] meeting and i knew
it wasn't for me
i knew those [__] were creepy
and at that time i was hanging out with
book b you know my mom had the bar
so it was like two blocks from my
mother's bar i walked into that boy
scout then
and you could smell the [__] sperm
and the abuse in there you could smell
it
and they were teaching us how to do
knots and they were looking at you weird
no no no no no no no no see that they
all these people you see today [__] up
of people from the 70s the boy scouts
[__] them up the catholic church and
i'll tell you who else
doctors they used to before this covert
i forgot because they're checking your
thermometer now
your temperature when you walk into a
building they put that thing in your
head like oh you're 98 whatever the [__]
ah i grew up in the 70s [__] when the
thermometer went up your ass
none of you [__] remember that
[__] your mom would put vaseline
at the moment and stick it up your ass
why do you think there's so many [__]
gay people today
because they're all getting back they're
all getting [__] uh what do you call
that [__] like when you go to vietnam
and [__]
you get flashbacks of the thermometer
that's why everybody got a flashback of
the thermometer
i look at it at the moment and i think
of it going up my ass and i freaked the
[__] out
how was that allowed in the 60s and 70s
that they would just
put in a jar of vaseline and stick it up
your ass and your mom would stare at you
like
like you know when you're sitting there
like a [__] [__] with a
thermometer up your ass looking around
the room
you're six or seven you're like what
what did i do to deserve this i mean
i'm a catholic i go to church i put a
dollar in the basket
why is there a [__] thermometer in my
[__] [__] you understand me
so when you see like 50 year olds like
me they're a little [__] up and they
get they turn gay like when they're 48
it all goes back to the [__]
thermometer i'm telling you right now
that the mobbing in the ass was not good
so that's what you should be selling the
[__] suit
the [__] doctors who put at the
moment up your ass not the poor and the
boy scouts too they were creepy too and
the catholic church that bunch of creeps
too
i'm a catholic but that don't mean i go
to church and hang out with those
[__]
because when you go churches become more
like a [__]
social thing now people don't go to
church because of necessity
or they feel love of god not that i'm
religious or anything you know me dog i
fly by the seat of my pants
there is a god i don't know what color
he is he could be chinese he could be
muslim i don't [__] know
but i know we have a higher power how do
i know because i'm [__] here that's
how i know
i wouldn't be here if there wasn't a
higher power somebody looked over me so
i don't even know how we got on this
conversation my point is
that the [__] catholics i
hold on i got to do a [__] hitter
listen just because we can't smoke weed
don't mean we have another situation do
you ever see these things huh
you live in california you haven't seen
these i'm in new jersey
what the [__] do you people think you're
dealing with just cause i'm in jersey i
think i lost a step
go [__] yourself i get 30 a day wherever
i'm standing
marijuana is legal
take that in your pipe and smoke it and
if that ain't enough for you look at
this
i got this little [__] thousand
milligram spray
this is the best right here oh yeah you
gotta [__] slide this over
and this gets the [__] party started
watch this i'm gonna show you
[__]
how i'm having fun [__] because
you're like joey you're not smoking
don't worry about me
i [__] lit myself on fire this
morning let's see what we got here
you gotta go like this you gotta press
it and then slide this [__] over
but once you do that you're in business
here you understand me
i don't want to squirt myself in the
[__] eyeball
you ever squirt yourself in the eyeball
with thc juice you're [__] done for a
week
you'd rather have somebody come in your
eye you ever jerk off and leave a little
on your finger and then rub your eye
and then an hour later you're walking
around like a [__]
moog the lord you got that red eye and
[__] you ever coming your girlfriend's
out anyway it doesn't matter
none of my business anyway none of my
business
[__] anyway so where was i here
i think we're just gonna stick with the
[__] asthma thing oh look at this one
bam you take this you go like this
you go like this
you open this [__] see now i
can't cause my hands all [__] greasy
i'm one of those greasy spanish people
you know what i'm saying
god damn it this is tremendous right
you go like this
you open this [__] up what's in
there
[Laughter]
a little breadstrip [__] how do
you put it down
1000 milligram spray
ah
the [__] thing you're dealing with
you're sitting there going joey eating
not smoking weed no more don't worry
about me just worry about yourself all
right
you got that susquehanna knock yourself
the [__] out with it i don't give a [__]
what you do
don't come to me with you have a
headache and your eyeballs are [__]
purple
me i'm smoking primo weed i'm trying to
stay healthy
i'm riding my bike i'm lifting weights
i'm eating good and most importantly i'm
[__] sleeping
that was killing me before now i'm
sleeping i'm in bed nappy nunu time last
night was a late night 12 30
but i was walking around the [__]
seven look at your timeline on twitter
or whatever i was walking around the
[__] seven
why because i don't [__] around you
gotta get up early i don't give a [__]
this colvin
you don't have to get up i'm working
from home who gives a [__]
get up you're getting lazy every [__]
day get up get up take a shower make
your bed
wash your [__] write your journal drink
your coffee smoke a joint
go for a walk then you [__] sip your
[__] fat ass on a computer
because at night you'll be sitting there
all [__] day like a monkey go out and
get a little vitamin d
put a smile on your face listen to the
podcast take a walk
then go back to your [__] desk sit
only for like an hour an hour and a half
that's
it because if not your back will be on
fire tell all those zoom [__]
to go [__] yourself
in 20 years we're all going to be zoomed
up you're going to see our eyeballs are
going to be like the guy from kung fu
let me just pupils we're all [__] up
because we're
going to be [__] zoomed up don't
don't [__] do that [__]
you listen i would love to have guests
but i [__] hate zoom
if i have to do it like for ryan sickler
or my brother's brendan or
i do it for them but i don't want to do
a [__] zoom with nobody
and zoom is going to kill your [__]
eyes i'm telling you in 20 years
we're going to remember this people are
going to have zoom eyes watch you're
going to hear that statement in 20 years
i'm so much from looking at zoom and
[__] dying people dying on facetime
all that [__] [__] you up you don't
need to watch that [__] the news
zoom none of that how do we even get on
this conversation i have no [__] idea
it doesn't matter it's [__] thursday
you know
tonight i gotta get on stage so i'm a
little rushed up that's what it probably
is today i'm getting on stage and uncle
benny's down there and [__] uh
point pleasant eight o'clock i'm just
doing my 40.
i don't even have eight you know what
i'm saying you think you got problems
you think you got problems like you had
to cut the cable i got problems i got to
do 40. i only got eight
so i got to go up there tonight and
[__] just go off the top of my head
have i done it before [__] all the
time do i feel like doing it no i wish i
had more material but the only way i'm
gonna have my material
is by trying it on stage i got a couple
things right now
i wrote out some stuff last week i wrote
out some stuff the week before
tonight we'll put it together we'll just
throw [__] out there and see what we get
it's just gonna be a nice little stew
that's all i got for you right now i
ain't ready for [__] 30
tickets i wouldn't do that to nobody
nobody deserves to do that [__] right
now
go to a [__] driving and pay all this
[__] money
and sit next to some guy you you [__]
smelling combustion and [__] like that
i try to avoid cold video situations
okay they're called code video
situations
a people call video situation this is
inside
he's got it down to 40 people i'm going
to tell him to push it back
10 because you know i spit when i talk
as it is that's all you need is corona
your eyeball
because i was outspent that's what we do
we do comedy you're up there
and you're [__] talking and you're
getting excited i spit
even when i just talk to people they'll
get a [__] spit in the eye from time
to time i'm sorry
people always used to tell me give me
the news not the weather i've always
been that [__] dude
but you know tonight i want it
controlled if i see something i don't
like
the lights get [__] because i'm not in
business to try to get anybody sick
that's why i don't like all this [__]
they call call video
situations and i'm watching people i'm
watching all the clubs that are open
and forcing people and trust me people
are getting sick they're just not
tracing it back
i'm watching all these code video
situation [__] suckers
wait till they come back i'm going to
all put them in check and i got to
charge them a little extra
just because they made money during cold
i want some of that money i was sitting
at home
relaxing so if you're gonna make an
offer for me
you better make it heavy because i'm
coming in heavy
that's it you've been opening [__]
giving people covered with your [__]
watered down drinks [__] now
uncle joey's coming i want some of that
money you made during covert
so get ready i ain't [__] around with
you [__] i'm gonna work out
this month
i got a movie in november december's
gonna be too cold to do dick
nobody knows that there's going to be
marches coburn might be back
i think the country will be locked down
again by december i hope not
god forbid hopefully i'm a [__] idiot
and i'm wrong but
i think once the first kid [__]
sneezes they're gonna lock
they're gonna start locking the [__]
down i know today for a fact
they're locking down parts in new york
city
some businesses are shutting down today
in new york city like some parts of
brooklyn or something don't quote me
but i know it's today effective the
seventh so
it's numbers are starting to spark up
again should that [__] bother you
do i want you to be scared and do i look
like [__] that [__] on abc news
that just scared you the whole time
every [__] tv show news show
has become they're like vincent price
you know the voice before thriller
everybody every news watch the news 15
minutes in your heart's beating like
you're [__] getting chased by three
puerto ricans i don't need that in my
life
and near do you need i've been a lot
a lot happier since i don't look at dave
visser no more
on abc world news tonight i've been a
lot [__] happy
look at me i'm just happy why
because i don't give a [__] it's like
this podcast right now
let me explain something to you i got a
lazy boy
i'm not getting it for two months i
ordered a [__]
generator for the house i'm not getting
it till february
my buddy bought a house he can't even
get appliances for his [__] house he
can't move in
he they told him trick or treat he was
going to have trick or treat at his
[__] house whatever halloween
he's not going to be able to move into
[__] january okay
we were having the same problems with
macs with cameras
you know getting electricians here doing
so we kept it as simple as it is
an iphone a light four walls
me you and this is all we need
if you guys are looking for a fancy
studio or for
you know oh my god go [__] yourself this
is just communication
this is just us trying to make each
other feel better this is all this is
don't sit there and pinpoint stupid
[__] [__]
you know yesterday i get 50 emails
where's lee lee's in milwaukee
when i had lee you were emailing me that
i'm an enabler
that i'm giving them drugs i'm making
them eat cheeseburgers
everybody you're an enabler i'm not a
[__] enabler
there's edibles all over here
you want to do them you do if you don't
go [__] yourself you know me
and we always got the lights off
because you never know what a speedy
those models are around here
so what was i talking about who the [__]
knows anyway uncle vinnie's yeah
i got no [__] material so if you have
no material why would you put yourself
in that position
for you people who keep emailing me
about parks casino
there's no parks casino it's canceled
till next year
i was gonna go i was gonna opt out for
the [__] beer and wine garden
but it only seats 50. if i'm going to
philly i want to see all you
[__] am i right on my wrong
i'm going to philadelphia i got to come
with three guns so why go to philly
to see 50 people i go to philly i want
to see 3 000
[__] that's one of my favorite
places in the [__] world
a cheesesteak and 3 000 philadelphians
it don't get no better than that [__]
right there so
philly will push it till next year i'll
try to do some shows down there there's
a punch line that's open
as things go on or whatever i miss you
you know i love you it's nothing
personal
we're just in the middle of a [__]
pandemic and there's nothing you can do
about it
and this is the same [__] with what was
going on but i'm trying to explain to
you about the podcast
how much longer did you want me to sit
on my hands for i have to wait for a
thousand things
[__] it this is as simple as
communication
as can be this is it if you don't like
it
i don't know what the [__] to tell you
eddie van halen is dead and i don't feel
so good myself
okay so go [__] yourself at least we're
trying to put it together here
at least we're trying for all you people
at least for trying it's better than not
giving you nothing
what do you want me to do send you a can
in the [__] mail and get strings and
we could all talk
like little [__] idiots this is the
best way to go right here we got each
other
i know you're feeling down and you're
going through a lot of [__] you don't
think i answer my patreon messages i
read those messages
a lot of people going through a hard
time right now especially
19 to 20 like three-year-old
you guys are in hell right now my heart
goes out to you i remember being 19.
i was confused as a dumb [__] as can be
i can't imagine a pandemic [__]
holding you down
you got to sit at home and [__] i
can't imagine so my heart goes out to
you guys
but don't give up now is not the time to
give up so you guys were raised
in an era where they gave you a medal
for showing up
and it [__] you guys up you guys don't
know how to act now
because it was just acceptable to show
up no you got to do
something it's not just going to happen
life just doesn't happen especially
during a [__] pandemic
i tell you that much if you don't go out
there and grab it
go check with your friends in la if
you're living in los angeles call around
they're robbing people in woodland hills
they're robbing people in north
hollywood
and what they're going to do is they're
going to create a circle and just close
that [__] valley and
so if you live in sherman oaks right now
i'd be looking for options i'd be
getting knives
darts [__] shooting stars i began
that i'd be getting ready to kill a
[__] if you live in sherman oaks
right now
because they're gonna surround you i
don't even know how we got to this
conversation
but anyway again that's the great thing
about reefer
it takes you to where you need to go
just a different direction you know what
i'm saying
like you ever go on waves what's that
what's that wave [__]
i love waves because it always makes you
take the longer way
on the way back you're like why'd you
make me go all the way around if i could
just
shot straight up the [__] road here
this waves take you to two other [__]
cities
and then it takes you back to where the
[__] you got to go i want the straight
line [__] sucker and that's what i'm
trying to do here
a straight line of [__] communication
especially with you 19 to 21
22 year olds listen to me get a book
read write help your parents
do whatever you can you're lost how do i
know because i was [__] lost
at 1920 you're basically [__]
[__]
i was i was [__] [__] let's say
84 i was 21 years old i could look you
guys straight in the face
and tell you i was [__] i didn't
have no concept i know how to hustle
i know how to steal i know how to do bad
things but i had no concept on how life
worked and how it came back to bite you
in the ass
i had no concept about hard work i had
no
intention of doing hard work you know i
thought that
the blue bird of happiness was just
going to show up and give me a check
once a month because my friends were
rich
it don't work that way it don't work
that way i had the guide here down
patreon sent me a message
i'm 21 i've been busting my hump and
everybody's moving around me everybody's
moving up around me
what do you just expect you're 20
[__] one
you gotta work you gotta get started you
got well i've been working for six
months and nothing's happened what do
you think's gonna happen in six months
that's what's gonna happen in six months
that's what happens in six months
a year that's what happens at six in a
year
oh i've been doing it for a year and a
half that's your year and a half
you gotta do it and you gotta do it well
do it with love
and do with [__] passion no okay
how the [__] do you think i got it you
think i got him because rogan made [__]
oh yeah but real good helped you out
sure he did he called adam sandler
sure he did he called the guy from
spider-man 2. oh
yeah he called david chase too and got
me in that you dumb [__]
no you got to put the [__] work in
you got to put the hustling you got to
show
i used to outwork the agent how the [__]
does the [__] client
outwork the agent that's what you need
to do
a lot of people sign with an agent like
my agent ain't doing nothing no
you're not doing nothing you're sitting
at home waiting for the phone to ring
when i have an agent that [__]
gets tortured
tortured i have an agent they got them
for years
i was torturing agents from 97
to 2010 i was because i would find out
about jobs
i would call them and go what are you
doing on this what are you talking about
call this [__] guy and tell them that
this and
they would look at me like what are you
talking about you got to call them well
i'll send them a headshot the headshot
ain't going to [__] work look at my
face nobody's going to hire me
call them and tell them i'm a [__]
savage and i would go to their office
and make them call them call them
call them because if you don't i will
i'll go down there and drop the package
off how do you think i got those movies
you think i got them because of my looks
no
i got him because i [__] outworked
the other guy
it was i was not gonna let it happen
you're not gonna let it happen that's
how you it's not gonna happen on your
[__] watch
if you want something if you want a
netflix special
you have to zero in on that [__]
you want to make more money
doing whatever the [__] you're doing you
got to revamp it you got to zero in on
that [__]
and what i mean zero win is i'll give
you an example
you could either have 10 mediocre
podcasts
or one really good one you ever think
about that
you could be a part of eight [__]
podcasts that nobody knows about
or put all your effort into one good one
and put everything you got into that
listen man i don't know about this joint
[__]
but i know when i did the church the
reason why you people are watching the
joint
is because you know one thing about me i
left my soul on the [__] table i
didn't sell my soul
i gave you my [__] soul i gave it to
you so you understood where i was coming
from
so after any anything after i gave you
my soul any word that would come out
you would understand what i'm saying and
you will understand what my heart was
i've said a thousand [__] horrific
things on that podcast
but i laughed at because to me that's
funny it's just words
they're not actions they're just words
you're just saying [__] that's
that's why i i don't understand
censorship
i never will because they're just words
when i did mafia three somebody got
offended
because i said the word [__] they had
to call uh
a crisis team in for this poor little
lesbian who had lights in her hair i
don't know why
she was a very sweet lady i'm not saying
that she was a bad lady or whatever
but she got that upset because i said
the word [__]
if you get upset over the word [__]
you gotta give yourself a [__] break
you gotta go for a walk you gotta get
some roller skates you gotta do
something with your [__] life
and that's what's going on right now
people are getting offended by [__]
words
and now you want to censor me you know
what chances you got a censoring me
none because you could take away my
sponsors
you could take away youtube you could
take away whatever [__] you want guess
what
i'm still gonna get to you i'm still
gonna get away to get to you i'll find
the [__] way
even if i gotta go in front of your
house and throw newspapers at you i
don't give a [__]
i've delivered newspapers for years so
when you want something
you go for it i don't give a [__] you
can't take nothing away from me that's
what these people understand
they tried three months ago four months
ago well you said this on the rogue
podcast that what are you talking about
have you ever
even [__] done a podcast with other
comics
and you're trying to lay in your
material in there and you even slip
[__] in like that you're not even
thinking about what are you talking
about they're just
words if you get offended at words it's
time for you to take a deep look into
your [__] heart and see what the [__]
is going on
it's not about words now if i come over
the house and hit you with a stick
that's an action if i [__] run over
your [__] dog
that's an action there's a problem if i
smack your wife in the face that's a
[__] action that's a problem
we have to censor that we gotta throw
that [__] jail
but words give me a [__] breather
why not what do you do with your [__]
life let's draw a [__]
let's draw a [__]
there you go [__] and you thought
it was just going to be a whole hum
[__] thursday
weren't you the [__] on it's uncle
joey [__]
we're here with queer what the [__] do
you want from me i'm here trying to put
the pieces together every day tomorrow
by the time you guys watch this i don't
know how you're gonna
i'm gonna be feeling terrible tomorrow
depending on my performance tonight
or whatever maybe i'll get covered
tonight and i'll be coughing and [__]
i have a white eye i have a zuma
whatever the [__]
i don't know but i'm gonna i'm just i'm
excited about getting on stage tonight
20 i didn't know what was going on with
me
and i got to tell you something guys i
don't care about the numbers
you know a couple of my friends called
me they said the podcast
didn't even matter to me you know what
mattered to me how i felt
ever since i did that podcast on sunday
been a complete different person
completely different person
that's what was missing from my life my
anxiety is down
my fear is down i got my balls back
listen man
your balls go away from time to time you
know every once in a while fear [__]
wins it really does
but at the end of the day you have
nothing to be fearful about
covered in three four days you drink
some [__] juice
don't lay on your back take the [__]
they gave [__] trump i smoked the
[__] they gave trump
you know what i'm saying but it's the
strain has been mutated right now
you're not gonna die you're gonna be a
little sick listen i got underlying
conditions but everybody's got a bunch
of [__] problems
so it's like shooting a game of [__]
dominoes it's the same [__] thing
so the fear is gone the fear has been
gone
the anxiety that i had of moving that's
last night i witnessed my daughter
with seven other [__] kids eight
other kids
playing on the [__] street i nearly
[__] cried
i wanted to [__] cry because in
california i couldn't get
one [__] play date to show up
here in new jersey we had nine kids over
there yesterday
and then like five of them went home for
dinner and
four of them stayed we ordered a [__]
pizza over there jimmy florentines
and then they [__] were going down a
dark hill
in like an electronic [__] car till
eight o'clock at night going back and
forth
thank god my wife went out last night
because she didn't know that i had her
out the [__] eight o'clock going up
and down
why because she needs to go out
you need these kids need to [__] get
social skills
in california right now my kid would
have been a mess if i would have made
this move
my kid wouldn't have made it out of this
that march to [__] july staying in
it wasn't working and i tell you i can
entertain you guys
i can entertain an audience but a
[__] seven-year-old
i don't have the physical capabilities
to do it anymore you know we ride a bike
you
play with the ball my daughter you want
to stick the bat up your [__] ass 10
times
because she always hits the ball to the
opposite side you got to go get it
you play with the ball with my daughter
for an hour you're [__] done you're
[__] done
people are like oh you're looking so
thin yeah cause i'm playing with my kid
all [__] day
that's a [__] nightmare my wife lost
seven pounds
sure but emotionally she couldn't handle
it like
she needed kids her age she needed young
kids older kids yesterday
there were six boys and she was playing
basketball
and they were pushing on her dog she got
hit with a whiffer boy yesterday guess
what
she didn't [__] cry she looked at me
i
and i looked at her i didn't say nothing
i expected her to cry
she didn't cry she's learning if you cry
in front of [__] six boys they'll
[__] eat you up alive
so last night when we got home i talked
to and i said next time you play
basketball with the boys you did a great
job
i think she even scored one [__]
basket i go you know we talked about
defense to look at that midsection
because they could fake you with their
eyes or their head just to focus on the
midsection when you're playing defense
and to keep your arms out for the ball
and i told her that when you go
in for rebounding to go in jump up with
the boys
and if they elbow you you elbow them
because that's how you gain respect as a
woman
is walking into that [__] circle and
banging it out with them
and there was harry and some other
little girl playing the other little
girl had [__] glasses
she's so cute she's five years old she
was in the circle playing with them
and that's what it's all about they
knocked it down they hit her with a
wiffle ball
you see me mad no that's what i wanted
i didn't want some [__] kid that was
allergic to [__] peanuts and
oh he's got add you know they got
nothing
they got nothing they're getting taught
on a [__] computer right now
so these kids are all [__] up so on
the other hand you gotta [__] give
them all the love and attention you can
if you have a child right now
nannies aren't gonna work right now you
gotta be on your kid especially if
they're sitting on a computer all
[__] day
thank god my daughter goes to school
twice a week thank god next week is one
day because it's jewish holiday monday
but the following week
it's four [__] days listen if it
lasts a month
i'll be surprised but i don't give a
[__] you know why
because we got enough kids in this
neighborhood for me to take her out
and play with other people i've made
friends with a couple of dads
a grandpa across the street and their
kids come over here and they go in the
yard
mercy goes into their yard i'm in a
different [__] situation
you don't seem to understand it wasn't
about comedy it wasn't about the comedy
store
it was it was about my family and what
was
best for them you know
at 29 i wouldn't have given a [__] i
would have still been in l.a slinging
dick [__]
smoking dope snorting coke i would have
snorted covered now
now you're [__] crazy they shot a guy
uh last weekend not even a mile from my
door
the no whole diner the the [__]
school saint paul's the
the school the preschool that my
daughter went to they broke into that
they stole the kids bicycles they stole
the kids bicycles they have those three
wheeler little [__] bicycles for
little kids they have like 10 of them
they stole the bicycles that's how bad
it is in my neighborhood
right now my ex name but my old
neighborhood
so you don't think i'm [__] happy
when i heard all that [__]
listen i feel for my friends that are
still left in california
i feel for dean delray i feel for a lot
of those guys i know a lot of those guys
are planning on leaving i know a lot of
guys are just sitting there waiting
because they think well the comics gonna
leave
and we're gonna take over the scene on
the looks of california there's not
gonna be a scene left
and you don't need some [__] fat
[__] felon to tell you that
you could see it for yourself if you
live in california they're not allowing
live performances
they're not allowing anything it's like
new york city right now
they're not allowing it there's a couple
clubs that are still open i'm not going
to mention their name
they're really banging it out i don't
blame them but they're in an area that's
not dangerous in new york
jersey's wide open they're doing tommy
outside here
bats are flying you know rich boss is
out there
for i think rich is up in connecticut
this week
if you're in the uh mohegan sun area
go see him up there i think my man jimmy
florentine is in akron ohio
and one of the clubs there one night go
check him out you know people are
starting to travel
me i'm gonna sit close to the house
right now i don't want to get on any
planes
um i'm still going to work this [__]
comedy thing out
i'm still going to keep writing and i'm
going to stick it out with this podcast
and once we get all this stuff we'll
move it out to the bar
or we'll keep it right here the only
thing that matters is that we reach
reach out to each other once a week we
continue to [__] do this podcast
twice a week whatever
and if you want to come on patreon come
on patreon i got to raise the tears i
got to change it all around
and it's not greed or anything like that
it was a recommendation from patreon
my manager is tight with the [__]
prez and blah blah blah
so we're doing three five and ten i
think fifteen
we're waiting on the final design of the
mind of joey diaz
which is basically all the crimes i've
done and all the wrongs i've done
and what turned it around was love
that's the mind of joey diaz so
this shirt's gonna be some type of brain
something like that i'll keep you posted
i'll show it to you whatever the [__]
you want to do i'm also
ordering a hundred hoodies
this is what i'm doing out of puerto
rican again
we can't get no more patches why because
they're made in china
so we had to go to a new manufacturer
for the patches
and it's going to take like four [__]
months so i don't have four months for
you people
and i'm getting your emails that you
want merged
i'm gonna tell you what i'm gonna do i'm
gonna make a special
collection hoodie thing i'm gonna put
them up soon i'll let you know
it's only gonna be a hundred and i'm
gonna write the number with a magic
marker on the side
one two three they're gonna be [__]
signed by me so it's gonna be a number
and a [__] signature and then
whatever [__] you wanna do it if you
wanna wipe your ass with it
if you wanna light it on fire if you
want to give it to your girlfriend
whatever the [__] you want to do you can
have one there's only going to be a
hundred of them
and they're going to go quick i'm doing
that because people have been asking me
for autographs and whatnot
so i just said we'll do it simple this
is the simplest way to do it
you get yourself a sweatshirt i'll let
you know when my wife will put it up
i'll tweet it out there's a hundred
[__] hooded sweatshirts
numbered from one to a hundred and i'll
tell you that you're a church savage
whatever you want to use it for i don't
even care if you don't want it or not
i do not care all i care about is that
you guys are doing well
that you're happy that you hear my voice
and that you know
everything's gonna be all right this
will pass
things cannot stay like this forever
this was just a little lesson to us
to smack us around i mean this never
happened in my lifetime before
i'm 57 years old i've never seen this
before so if you're 31 or 32 or 22 and
you're scratching your [__] head
i've never seen this or lived through
something like this before
so this is new to me also what i will
tell you is
this will pass i've had shitty times in
my life i've had really shitty times in
my life
you've been in prison on christmas day
and don't feel good
don't feel right even though you have
friends and you're giggling
and you're eating nutter butters it's
still christmas and you're in a [__]
prison
so things will pass i promise you that
with all my heart
that a year from now hopefully we'll be
laughing at this are you
is it going to be a vaccine is it just
going to disappear is it just going to
go away
i don't have those answers for you i'm
not a [__] scientist
you know everybody's waiting for a
vaccine one of the vaccines gonna come
are you gonna go down there and be the
first one to [__] take it
shut the [__] up shut the [__] up so i
don't even take a quote a flu vaccine
i don't believe in the flu vaccine my
wife and my daughter doing every [__]
six months they're sniffling
so what's the [__] difference anyway
you toughing it out i got i built my
[__]
uh whatever from [__] going on planes
for 20 [__] years my immune system
today i lift weights i drink water i
walk a little bit
you know i ride the bike i hit the bag
that's how you build your immune system
you know
i haven't been around a lot of people
that's what scares me right now
about tonight that i haven't been around
30 40 people
you know so there's no greeting meets
you know the club doesn't want
responsibility for it we don't want
nobody to get sick
so we're gonna end the show i'm gonna
walk out and that's it
and once this thing clears off we'll do
meet and greets i'll let you rub my
balls whatever the [__] you want to do
i'll let you that's gonna be a new
option during uh
once we go back on the road next year
i'm getting a little older you're not
going to see my balls anymore you've
been seeing them for 20 years
so i'll let you like touch him or sniff
him whatever [__] you want just a joke
it's a joke people i'm not going to let
nobody stuff my balls
my balls smell [__] horrible how do i
know because i live with them
sometimes i could smell them through the
sweatpants you've been [__] writing
you can smell your nuts
that's when you know it's time for a
[__] shot well it hasn't happened in
a while
but i know for a fact from time to time
you're out there sweating riding your
bike
you go back inside you start writing and
all of a sudden you get that hint of
[__] ball
nut spray and look what you got the crop
preserver
i think it even says it on there it's a
[__] nut washer there
it keeps you nice and beautiful that's
manscape they ain't
[__] around over that manscaped
suckers they take good [__] carry it
just in case your nuts think i don't
know it's none of my business
i used to use uh you know what's good
for nut stink
some is eve vaginal scrub it's what
women use on their monkeys
you take that and put it on your nut
sack and you wash with a loofah oof
oof a woman will need sunglasses to look
at your [__] balls you understand me
they're nice and shiny
you [__] get that manscape you shave
your balls and then you buff them out
like a bowling ball with a towel
like a [__] with uh like a [__] you
ever have a bowling ball none of your
[__]
ever have a bowling ball polisher you
get like a little one you use like a
like one of those face masks you like
just take an old face mask
and just take your nut sack them and
bounce them back that's like
that's what you do people don't know
this [__]
you don't know this [__] they don't put
two and two together that's what you're
doing you keep getting that i do it
every ever since this corona virus i
figured out
you get one of those little masks you
just get your balls and jiggle them in
there
and it keeps them tight you spray a
little this is the refresher but they
have another one
that i still got that they don't make it
tights in your balls
it doesn't make it look like an elbow no
more it makes it look slick and then you
put the vaginal scrub on it
and it gives it that shine you know what
i'm saying women you've got to tell
ladies before you suck
my dick put your sunglasses on because
if the sun gets [__]
you're going to go blind you know what
i'm saying
[__] a little lights off of people
you gotta [__] watch out
we're here with queer [__] it's
uncle
joey's joint coming direct at you on a
beautiful thursday afternoon
the 8th of october today's the
anniversary of my uh
one of the guys that raised me his name
was rob running
robert ronnie uh the family reunion i
went to a couple weeks ago i put the
picture up he was the father of that
family
and today was his birthday and we used
to [__] rock and i always
think about about him on this day like i
love the guys so
uh once i finish the podcast i'll
[__] call the kids
remind them it's bob's birthday today he
used to [__]
he was the best because when you came in
at night
when we come in at night we coming at
anytime we had no [__]
uh whatever the [__] you call it no
curfew over there you came home when you
came home
but if you came home and you mingled in
the kitchen
within a couple of minutes you would
hear this
he'd be smoking in his room he'd let it
sink in his room the lighter
meant that he knew
you came in he wanted you to know that
he was up and he heard you come in
so he would always work the lighter if
you heard the lighter a second time
that means you had to disperse because
that means you're talking too much in
the kitchen he can't go back to sleep
once he would get up once you woke him
up with the door he would light the one
[__] cigarette
but if he if you heard that second one
the next one he would just come out and
yell at you
[__] hit you with a pile or whatever
the [__] and tell you to go downstairs
but i always remember him from just that
[__] light of noise that was it
that meant he knows your home we gotta
go downstairs and that's it and that's
that [__] you know what i'm
saying
i got things myself i got problems
myself you guys think you're the only
ones with [__] problems don't let
that be the case at all
please don't let that be the case at all
everybody's going through something
right now
financially emotionally
psychologically right now is a tough
time for everybody so please
don't beat yourself up right now don't
if you're not moving to your mom's
basement moving to your mom's basement
that's what your [__] mom is there
for
we think she's there for just to stay i
mean there's things you you have to do
right now that you're doing
that they're hard for you and i get it
listen i had to [__] pick up my
family
i wouldn't i never wanted to give up
that podcast office
never never in my life did i want to
give up that podcast office
that office was perfect that office cost
me 750 a [__] month
250 for [__] internet that i could
[__] i could have lived in there
i had a refrigerator a tv in there you
could have lived in there taking a
shower at the ymca if
you're smart you rent that office and
[__] just
live at the ymca when i lived in seattle
that's what i did i rented an office
it was a buck a quarter a month no
bathroom
you had a bathroom but no shower i had
to [__] out the the window
and then take a shower at the gym but
when you're a comic
and you want what you want you don't
have that much money you make it work
for you
and that's what you have to do during
these times of colvin you know the other
day somebody said to me well
something happened 14 million people
watched
the championships last year in the nba
and this year they only got four million
people
well think about how many people had to
give up their cable service
think about how many people don't have
time for [__] basketball or more
that their lives changed your life has
changed
think about it my life has changed i can
do two podcasts a week and maybe a
couple other things but that's
it why because my daughter's home five
days a week
right now she's at the park that's the
only reason why i'm able to do this i
can't do this sister's home
be down here yelling and [__]
spraying [__] thc
spray anyway it's time for another one
who the [__] are you kidding
what are you [__] nuts so what you
thought i was sitting here like a monkey
jersey
[__] you i'm smoking reefer with three
hands having a good old [__] time i
don't go nowhere
the gym is right down the corner the
supermarket is around the corner
shoprite's close to me there's a carvel
i don't go
i'm trying to [__] no diabetes for
uncle joey
corona is strong i don't want level two
diabetes
if i'm just minding my business getting
high at home
i go for a walk i take a bike ride and
smoke a joint
so nobody needs to see me none of my
neighbors see me there's a little
[__] abandoned lot over there
i may believe i'm taking a breather and
drinking water what i'm really doing is
banging out
a [__] number that'll kill you and
everything's taken care of
right now my biggest concern is the
emails i'm getting
whether it's on facebook twitter
[__] instagram [__] uh
patreon i'm getting some [__]
sad emails they're very sad emails
and listen man i'm not a a psychology
major or nothing like that
but i know what sadness is i know what
confusion is
i know what it is to want i know what it
is to [__]
you know i know what all those things
are and just bear with me
it's going to get better when i don't
[__] know
if i knew that i wouldn't be here
talking to you i'd be at the [__]
track
watching horses die as they better a
horse is still dying i don't even know
remember for a long time horses are
dying
i don't even know but we're gonna get
through this
you know you're having a hard time get a
[__] notebook get closer to your
family
what do you think your family's there
for what do you think they're there for
just so you think your mother just
picked you out of her [__]
just so you could walk around with
another biblical chord no
talk to them let them know how you feel
one of the biggest things i did
and we've been together for 20 years in
march when i was going to the deepest
fear like towards the end of march when
i put on 14
[__] pounds from eating edibles and
eating everything in the [__] house
i figured out that i had to get closer
with my wife or this was not gonna work
this was not gonna work i had to
eliminate
whatever anger issues i had or fears i
had
when i was in the house because i'm the
[__] man of the house
so if i appeared scared to them then
they would be scared
but i made a [__] a commitment to
myself that i was going to work with my
wife as a team during this
we weren't going to work against each
other i wasn't going to turn on her or
anything
and because of covert we've gotten tired
i mean they surprised the [__] out of me
i thought by now i would have stabbed my
wife
18 times i love my wife with everything
i got and especially after my
sister-in-law passed
i see all my brothers going through now
it makes me love my wife even more
because i appreciate it more
you can't take these women for granted
and i don't
so whether you have a sister a brother a
wife a girlfriend
listen man this is not the time to be
going to war with them
it's not the time if somebody aggravates
you then stay the [__] away from them
but if somebody's your ally right now
during this covert period during this
period of isolation and whatnot
make them your [__] ally man whatever
whatever
split the sandwich pay for the sandwich
there's no reason to argue but you're
close people your brothers your family
right now
you need them now more than ever
now you know how f is for family you
know bill burr this year is f is for
final
i love [__] billboard f is for
this is it the quarantine is for family
whatever you call it
they don't have to be related to you get
yourself a little quarantine
family that you know that they're clean
you're clean
and that's who you talk i don't care if
you like [__] tim allen if you talk
through a [__] fence this is all you
want to get through this
you gotta rap you gotta rap rapper
people you know how i know because it
worked for me
when i was going through my [__] when i
first landed here in jersey
i went to see the first guy i went to
see was guy tabasco on a saturday night
i just drove the [__] seek office and
we sat in his backyard
and just rapping with him i remember i
refused to take the mask off
i refused to take the [__] mask off
and after a while i was like what am i
doing he's
[__] a social distance and i remember
taking the mask off and i remember like
shedding like 10 [__] pounds off my
shoulders
i was like oof and then driving home i
was a little paranoid but the next day i
woke up no sore throat
if you wake up and your throat feels
like you sucked a thousand [__] then
maybe you were in the wrong [__] area
but every morning that i wake up and
there's no sore throat i'm like [__]
i can't believe i didn't get covered you
know but
rapping is what gets you through this
you sitting there watching tv and
watching watching
the computer you know i don't somebody
checked on me on patreon like hey man
you don't post on the weekends no
i don't post on the weekends and there's
two reasons why
number one i need my time off and number
two i want you guys to take your time
off that [__] internet you don't need
to be on it sunday night you go back on
it just in case somebody sent you a
message
it's important for monday but besides
that i want you out of the house i don't
post on saturday and sunday
and i do that for a reason not because i
don't love you [__]
but it's because i don't want you to get
computer [__] addicted
get out of that [__] house it's too
easy you can sit on that computer for
[__] hours
like after this is over get up take a
[__] hike
after you watch this get up and take a
[__] hike you know you that's it
take a hike then come back and then put
on burton and bill
and then take another hike and come back
and put on jre
come back and listen to lee's new
podcast whatever the [__] you want to do
ozzy's boneyard but you can't sit down
more than an hour 15 minutes
that's the [__] new rule from now on
an hour 15
you go out for a little walk now in
three weeks four weeks
you're not gonna be able to do that
right so let's do something different
i'm gonna be able to go into another
room maybe do 20 push-ups
five sets of 20 push-ups anything
anything to get your mind
off of what's going on right now is
gonna be [__] great
i'm excited that now we're together
again i get to talk to you [__]
twice a week
i get to answer your [__] emails and
now we got a common ground again i was
lost without you [__]
if you want me to tell you the truth
that's the truth that's why the anxiety
is gone ever since i've done the podcast
i'm done i feel 100 better because you
guys are handled i'm handled
listen this is my therapy and for some
of you guys this is your therapy
i don't know why i don't know why i
didn't ask for it this way
i just wanted to talk [__] for an hour
and be funny and [__] get your mind
off things
but obviously it's become something
different for you people so i'm here
i'm here you can get to me i'm
accessible
if you email me on any other [__]
things you know
if you email me on messenger on facebook
you don't see those [__] for 20
years
just message me at the [__] my
facebook whatever joey d is whatever the
[__] it is
if you message me on twitter on
mattflavor i'm there
instagram my man mikey one by one does
that for me
and if you're talking [__] he don't even
tolerate you he tells me he don't even
tolerate you
if you call them with something good or
you got a problem with you yeah what
wheat are you smoking today what are you
kidding me how old are you who got a hat
with a [__] propeller what weed are
you smoking what do you think i'm
[__] smoking
ah thousand milligrams
when i get it none of your [__]
business do the math [__] suckers and we
also have the asthma inhaler
for some of you [__] we don't
[__] around here uncle joey's joint does
not [__] around
the difference between this and the
church is the attitude
i have had it with you [__] not
with you guys i love you guys
with people i have had it especially
those california people want me to
[__] out the death i've had it so now i
just tell you how it is direct
that's just never gonna happen in my
life again you know it just got a little
too crazy the phone calls
people acting hurry around no no no no i
got a little
too out of control we're not doing that
no more the game
is different now i thought about what
happened i
analyzed it and we'll put a different
game plan together so
i'm not [__] around no more i'm not
in the [__] mood i'm too [__] old
i got a couple years of doing this [__]
i'm gonna enjoy it
i'm gonna do it my way and i'm gonna
have a good time and another thing is
i'm not getting censored
i don't give a [__] what you're telling
me or what i can't say i'm not joining
no companies
i don't give a [__] if you don't put me
on your podcast i don't give a [__]
how's that one for you
i'm too old to give a [__] and so the
[__] are you if you're worried about a
word
you don't want to listen to this podcast
or any other podcast all you got to
worry about is your health
your family and what type of friend
you're being to your friends
that's it everything else is background
[__] music i talk to lee twice a day
you talk to lee twice a day no twice a
day i call that [__]
he's up in milwaukee he told me
yesterday he's starting to get cold
i said what do you expect things and he
don't know he's he's going from
he's going from milwaukee to buffalo to
get a [__]
covet test and then he's going to dip
down to boston
he doesn't know that the snow is going
to be behind them it's going to be like
a scene in [__] trains planes and
automobiles
when he's driving he's going to be
looking back and [__] and like led
zeppelin 2 is the [__] snowstorm
he doesn't know he's driving across
michigan he goes maybe i'll drop
down i'll drop the how down are you
gonna [__] go what are you gonna go
to mexico and shoot back up to boston
you just gotta go across you gotta you
gotta [__] go through michigan then
whatever's next to michigan on the other
side
i think he's hitting all [__] penguin
states he doesn't know it he's like ah
it's going to be great no it's not
if it's 30 degrees by you right now in
milwaukee what is it going to be in
three [__] weeks
and what are you driving into boston's
already going to get snow any [__]
day now
it's starting to get a little cold here
not i'm lying to you it's starting to
get a little colder at night
you can feel the temperature dropping at
night
but in the daytime the sun's still out
today it's just a little windy you've
heard the wind hit the [__] window a
little bit
it's just a little windy but up there is
[__] real
we're gonna get cold down here too this
is a cold neighborhood
you know joe a bunch of people were
goofing after the winter
i'll move to san antonio or wherever
texas let me tell you something
uncle joey is prepared for the winter i
did the toughest winters of my life here
and then you [__] forget
another i did another 12 winters in
colorado
and those are winters i did the winter
of 83 where it snowed 25 days in a row
have you ever been around 25 days in a
row no so shut the [__] up i'm gonna be
fine
you get jacket you get some of that
[__] long underwear
a lot of hot cocoa with no sugar reefer
and put a hooded sweatshirt on to keep
the heat in
you're gonna be tip top [__] magoo
and that's it
and that's that for this segment of
uncle joey's joint
listen man i'm just happy to be doing
this
trust me i'm telling you i'm happy to be
helping whoever needs this
to be helping out whoever needs this you
know some people need to
watch podcasts or whatever uncle joey's
here for you
i'm trying to put this together i'm
trying to find my voice on this podcast
it's going to be a few weeks but guess
what i'm gonna grind it out
with this with you if you enjoy it
[__] subscribe if you don't enjoy it
don't subscribe
but don't send me a note uncle joey you
suck no
don't send me that note you don't need
to you could be sending your mother a
card that says i love you mom
instead of sending hate send love
instead of going on [__] uh
what's that [__] well i went there to
eat and the waitress didn't give me a
tip who gives a [__] just don't go there
again
send your father a message tell him that
you love him send your sister a message
tell her that you love her
before you give somebody a bad review
tell somebody you love
call somebody email somebody you love
them that's positive
but if you're gonna sit there and say oh
i'm not gonna watch it because
you the picture the delight in the
picture of bruce lee
get it together get it together that's
what yeah that's that's your message to
me
you could have wrote something positive
to your family member or to your
girlfriend i
to eat your [__] tonight with benoit
balls and your [__]
something right or wrong you know what
benoit balls are they're tremendous
these little string of balls
and you put them up a girl's ass and you
look at that [__] [__] and every
every click you pull a notch out you
know what i'm saying it's like
and then you you gather up that little
[__] phone you wait for that monkey
gets nice and steamed and they rip that
out like the fourth
you know those things that you pop on
[__] new year's eve happy new year
pop you pop that [__] thing out they
get all crazy
i did ben my balls in my 20s it's been a
long time i didn't put them up my ass
some chick put them in her little
monkeys i lived in colorado a long
[__] time ago
who gives a [__] it wasn't for me i
don't like pulling things off people's
ass
i thought a kid he was going to follow
him that's all you need you're eating
somebody's monkey
you pull out a benoit ball the hook gets
caught to the [__] liver
and now i got to go to the hospital with
what was like jack crusto
with a [__] stick with with a string
with a hook on your ass connected i
don't need that [__] in my life
anyway this this is
this is where my mind goes you see what
i'm saying when i when i don't have you
guys in my life
this is why i need you guys in my life i
need to i need to rap this [__] out
if not we're gonna [__] just die
but i love you guys and we'll be back uh
monday morning
nice and early in the am i hope you
enjoy this i'm trying my [__] hardest
i'm just here to tell you i love you
you're gonna pull through this
trust me this is gonna pass we're gonna
laugh at all this years from now
and [__] and stay healthy avoid
covertial situations if you see a
cavalia situation
you go the other way what's a covodial
situation
well it might be covered that's it if
you don't want to get sick you can avoid
it
that's it and that's that take care of
yourself have a great weekend
like i said we're gonna raise the tears
on patreon on monday it's gonna be three
bucks who gives a [__]
you wipe your ass for three bucks all
day you're out there [__] around
jumping up and down you got good content
i take care
and you know the guy's a good guy we're
helping out people we're trying to put
things together for people
i love you guys have a great weekend
don't forget to support our sponsors
whether it's [__] landscaped whether
it's
[__] the blue chew whether it's
express bpm
cbd lion all those companies please
support them
i love you guys and now we'll read the
ads
stay black love you
i want to thank you for listening to
uncle joey's joint today
and it's brought to you by blue chew
listen
remember when you're when you wake up in
the morning your dick was [__] hard
like a [__] you had a salute to
helmet and [__]
there's nothing wrong there's nothing
worse than [__] having dead dick when
i ripped my [__] hamstring
my dick wasn't working too good but you
know what uncle joey's to fix that how
blue chew it's the first chewable dick
pill
same fda approved active ingredients as
viagra
and cialis listen to me this isn't that
horny goat weed you get from
[__] whatever his name is muhammad
whatever the [__] the guy
is at the [__] liquor store this my
friend is science
and it it whips right to your [__]
door in a discreet package
nobody knows nothing blue tube is
prescribed online
by licensed physicians so you don't have
to go to the doctor
and wait with a [__] costume on and a
[__] mask on
and wait in line the pharmacy and then
the pharmacist looks at you
and she giggles [__] that [__] blue chew
is cheaper than any pharmacy
and you can take them anytime day or
night
even on a full stomach who's better than
you you'll be [__] [__] up
with that dick you'll be putting up
pictures of
you over the house banging [__] nails
with your dick
putting up pictures so go to
bluetooth.com right now that's blue
b-l-u-e-chew.com and get your first
shipment
free when you're pressing code church
just pay five dollars shipping and
handling
and that's blue like the color of your
[__] helmet
when it gets to pop in that [__] ass
thank you blue chew for coming so again
go to bluechew.com and press in church
and just pay
five hours for shipping again that's
bluechew.com
the church is also brought to you by
manscaped let me tell you something
they don't [__] around over at manscape
all you [__] doing your zoom
[__] and your hairs are sticking out of
your nose like a [__] wildebeest
enough with that [__] i don't the only
thing i want to see in your nose is a
[__] coke rock all right that's it
falling out hitting the table when
everybody loosens the ceiling making
believe like they came down from the
[__] ceiling
listen you know all about manscaped i've
done the videos i told you all about it
you know they keep your [__] ball
safe i trim my [__] balls the other
night i'm not i'm showing to you right
now i'm trimming
right out of line now you can do the
same job to your nose
clean the corona right out of there with
9 000 rpm motor and a blade that moves
360 [__] degrees
when you weed whack your nose everything
goes whether you got a big
or a [__] small nose whether you got
a [__] one of those nose that goes
over and you can smoke a cigarette
the weed whack will work for you it's
got a coat or this
designed to fit all [__] noses okay
and you might think joey isn't this just
an old man's problem no
how are you gonna eat [__] if you can't
breathe through your [__] nose think
about it
get your face looking good as your balls
with the weed whacker from manscape
and one thing you put up your nose
that's good for you
right now the joint family gets 20
off and free shipping when you press in
special code for this
it's nose pubes nose pubes at
manscape.com
you'll never get a deal like this on
nose candy anywhere
i'm giving you 20 off and free shipping
at
manscape.com with code nose pubes
go to manscape.com right now and press
in those pubes
and get your [__] weed whacker and
last but not least
my all-time favorite expressvpn
why nobody needs to know your [__]
business all right
you don't take a [__] in front of people
do you no you go behind the [__] wall
you're not an animal
that's the same reason i use expressvpn
it encrypts your data
when you're online no one can see what
you're up to okay
if you want to see [__] africans
hitting each other in the head with
sticks
they got it and the best part you can
watch movies and tv shows
from all over the world because they
hide your location
so you can watch that secret [__] they
only get in other countries you
understand me
and they show you real [__] dude you
ever seen horror in europe they just
killed [__] and
and you know they don't even they don't
even tell you the name of the [__]
cast
they just say all right pfpm knight
fights dog fights
interest elba this is the real [__] here
express
vpn works with any streaming service
hulu bbc
netflix it's fast no buffering and it
streams in hd what the [__] else you
want
and you ready for this one it works on
all devices
so right now hit the special link right
now go to expressvpn.com
church and you get an extra three months
of expressvpn
for free that's three months for free
support the show and watch what the [__]
you want and protect yourself
with expressvpn.com
church i want to thank manscape i want
to thank bluechu
and i want to in fact expressvpn but
most importantly
i want to thank the joint [__]
family because we're going deep
again have a great weekend and see you
[__] on monday
lights off it's over [__] go home